hello it's Dad I'm I'm getting out soon
[Music]
mom ask Dad for the money I'll handle it
I need money Tyler
maybe if you let me see him I might be a
little more generous
[Music]
and the time I have left I would like to
spend it with you I'll do it on one
condition
you pay me rent
oh my God you're still so beautiful
you're a tenant that's it
generations to come it's been ages since
I've seen this place let's dump filled
with bad memories I'm not that guy
anymore
[Music]
I'm tired of being picked on all the
time I'm gonna take you somewhere you
always have to protect yourself
dirty Bulldogs in town huh you think
that's a good idea you're an attic
I'm gonna ask you one last time or what
don't come in here now like there's some
hero because you're not
you can't stop me from seeing them no
watch me
I promise I will never let them harm you
again
I'll make up for who I was or what I did
but let me be your father for once
why did you go to jail which time wait
how many times did you go to prison more
than I care to remember